Okay Michael do you have an answer?
>> I have an answer indeed.
>> Okay, what's the answer?
>> Okay, maybe I don't have an answer indeed.
But I have I have the ability to compute one.
>> Okay.
>> I'm, I'm doing some math.
>> So why don't you walk me through the math you're doing.
>> I got .32776.
>> That is correct Michael.
>> Woo-hoo. That was trickier than I thought.
>> Okay well, show me what you did.
>> Alright, so the
first thing I did is I said, okay, well this
is not so hard, because, from the start-state, if I
execute up, up, right, right, right. Each of those things
works the way it's supposed to do independently with probability .8.
>> Yep. And so, .8 raised to the 5th power, gives
me the probability that that entire sequence will work as intended.
>> Exactly. And what is .8 to the 5th? Do you know?
>> 32,768. with a decimal point in front
of it, because you know, powers of 2.
>> Wow. That is correct. But I notice that 32768
is not 32776. No they differ by a little smidge.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So this is what occured to me next is,
is there anyway that you could have ended up falling into
the goal from that sequence of, of commands not following the
intended path. So since actions can have unintended consequences, as they
often do.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I was going to ask okay, so if I go up in the
first step, there's a probably .1 that I'll actually go to the right.
>> Yep. From there, if I go up, there's
a 10% probability that I'll actually go to the right.
>> Mm-hm.
>> From there, the next thing I do is take the
right action, but that can actually go up with some probability, .1.
>> Mm-hm, yep.
>> And then another .1 to get to for
the next right action to actually cause an up to happen.
>> Mm-hm. And then finally, that last right might
actually execute correctly and bring me into the goal. So
I could go underneath the barrier, instead of around the
barrier with that same sequence. It just isn't very likely.
>> Okay. Well how unlikely is it?
>> Alright. So I did .1 times .1 times .1 times .1
times .8. huh, so the .1 to the 4 times .8 and
that's right so this is the probability that the, 4 of the sequences, 4 of
these go wrong. In fact exactly the first 4 go wrong. And the last one goes
right. Right. And that's equal to, some
very, very small number. And when you add
it up. You end up with .32776. In fact that's equal to 0.00008. And that's how
you get that number and that's correct. And you'll
notice that this this sequence happens to work out to
be the second sequence that, we had options for. Yeah,
the other thing that took us to the goal, right.
>> Yeah.
>> Was exactly the probability of executing that action
executing that sequence of transitions given the first command.
>> Yeah, and I think it would work the other way, too. No,
it wouldn't quite work the other way. If you had done the sequence
right, right, what is it? Right, right. Up, up right?
>> Yeah.
>> In order for that one to work out, you'd add .8 to the
5 and working. And, for it to work out wrong but work out right, the
right would have to send you up and then the ups would have to send
you right, and then, yeah, so it would actually work out to be the same.
>> Yeah.
>> So no matter which of the two sequences you came
up with, they would have the same probability of succeeding. Neat.
>> Nice. That's actually kind of cool. So, good
job, Michael. Very good job on the quiz. A
lot of people forget this part. And, in fact, if
you forgot that part, and got, just this part
right, we actually let you pass. But it was wrong.
>> I was kind of expecting you to get
it wrong, but I'm glad you got it right too.
>> Thank you Michael, I appreciate your faith in me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I wrote the quiz. Actually, I stole this from a book,
>> Oh. which, whose little words are now showing
up in front of you, exactly where you can
go through the details of this quiz. Okay, alright, Michael. So you
might ask yourself why I brought this up, and the reason I brought
this up is because, what we did in the first case where we
just came up with the sequence up up right right right, is we
sort of planned out what we would do in a world where
nothing could go wrong. But once we introduced this notion of uncertainty, this,
this randomness, this stochasticity, we have to do something other than work out
in advance what the right answer is, and then just go. We have
to do something a little bit more complicated. Either we have
to try to execute these, and then every once in a
while, see if we've drifted away. And then re-x, re-plan, come
up with a new sequence wherever it is we happen to end
up, or we have to come up with some way to
incorporate all of these uncertainties and probabilities. So that, we never
really have to think, rethink what to do in case something
goes wrong. So, what I'm going to do next is I'm going to introduce
the framework, that's very common, that people use as a
way of capturing this stuff, capturing these uncertainties directly. Okay?
>> Hm.
>> You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Excellent.